After season 7's staggering finale, viewers
were left with questions they never even anticipated.
From ice dragons to Cleganebowl and the fate
of some of our favorite characters, here's
a spoiler filled look at all the questions
Game of Thrones needs to answer in its final
season.
Ever since they first hatched, Daenerys' three
dragons have been an integral part of the
show.
However, in Game of Thrones' most recent season,
one of Daenerys' dragons, Viserion, was felled
by the Night's King and fell under his thrall.
So what does this undead dragon mean for Westeros
in the next season?
With so many theories floating around, it
can be hard to keep track, but fans can expect
a dragon showdown at the very least.
Season 7's finale confirmed a long-held fan
theory that will seriously affect the final
season: Jon is not Ned Stark's bastard son,
but is instead a Targaryen, and the rightful
heir to the Iron Throne.
That revelation means that Jon and Daenerys
are in for a nasty surprise, since they spent
the season 7 finale becoming very intimate.
Considering that Jon has promised to help
Daenerys secure the Throne for herself, things
may get even more awkward when she realizes
her new lover isn't just her biggest rival...
he's also her nephew.
So far, several names on Arya's infamous revenge
list have been killed by other people, and
she's personally taken down a few herself.
"I want you to know that.
The last thing you're ever going to see is
a Stark smiling down at you as you die."
However, there are still several huge names
on her list that haven't yet been taken down.
Though she thinks the Hound is dead, he's
actually still alive.
Likewise, the executioner who killed her father,
as well as big bads like The Mountain, Melisandre,
and Cersei Lannister are still on the loose
for Arya to hunt down.
But will she be the one to end their lives?
Cersei Lannister has always been one of the
show's most despicable and complicated characters,
and currently, she holds the Iron Throne.
In the last season, she dropped a big pregnancy-related
bombshell:
"We will defeat it.
For ourselves, for our house, for this."
As to the question of whether Cersei truly
is pregnant, Jeremy Podeswa, the director
of the season 7 finale, chimed in to say that
he believes that she wasn't lying.
But if she's telling the truth, it could hint
at her final fate, thanks to a handy prophecy.
"Will the king and I have children?"
"No, the king will have twenty children.
And you will have three."
Of course, Cersei already had three children.
But in the books, this prophecy includes another
warning: that Cersei will be vanquished by
her valonqar, or little brother.
Though Cersei has always assumed this means
Tyrion, Jaime is just a few minutes younger
than she is.
Many fans believe that if she really is pregnant
with his child, the pregnancy could cost Cersei
her life.
Melisandre, the Red Woman, has been an increasingly
mysterious character on a show filled with
mysterious characters.
Even so, she's done her part when needed,
like when she raised Jon Snow from the dead
in season 6.
In season 7, during a meeting with Varys,
the two agree that Melisandre should head
to Volantis.
"I will return, dear spider.
One last time."
"M'lady…"
"I have to die in this strange country.
Just like you."
Although their conversation is riddled with
clues for superfans, it's hard to decipher
what role Melisandre will play in the show's
final season.
Jaime Lannister might have become a fan favorite
over the course of the show's run, but he's
still a morally ambiguous character.
However, through his journey with Brienne,
Jaime seems to have turned several corners.
He even swore to fight against the White Walkers
rather than assist Cersei in her attempt to
shore power.
Still, Jaime's always been loyal to his sister
when push comes to shove, so the question
remains: will he put aside petty squabbles
in the face of the White Walker invasion?
Or will he stay a Lannister through and through?
Either way, he'll have a debt to pay.
"And of course, you have also heard the phrase,
'A Lannister always pays his debts.'"
One of the most anticipated showdowns in the
entirety of Game of Thrones is referred to
as Cleganebowl, which would see the Clegane
brothers pitted against each other.
The Mountain has become a brainless, mute
slave of Cersei, and the Hound has gone through
his own trials that's left him eager for revenge.
Simply put, here's not much standing in the
way of these two fierce warriors duking it
out.
When the two reunited at the end of season
7, The Hound seemed to promise that Cleganebowl
was on the horizon.
"Doesn't matter.
That's not how it ends for you, brother.
You know who's coming for you.
You've always known."
It's still unclear what role Bran will play
in the final season, but naturally, fans have
plenty of ideas.
Fans have theorized that Bran exists in every
moment of time simultaneously or even that
Bran himself could actually be the mysterious
and powerful Night's King.
It's also possible that Bran was the catalyst
for the Mad King's descent into insanity.
No matter what the answer is, it's clear that
Bran's role as the Three-Eyed Raven will have
a huge impact on final season.
Some of the most meaningful moments on Game
of Thrones have come when beloved characters
reunite after being separated for long periods,
and season seven looks to be full of these
moments.
One hotly awaited reunion is between Jon and
Arya Stark, two Starks who have always been
extremely close.
And fans are also curious to see if Arya and
the Hound reconnect after his supposed death.
Likewise, who wouldn't want to see Sansa and
Tyrion reunite after their forced marriage
ended up with some unexpectedly sweet moments?
As the cast has dwindled, these long-awaited
reunions are sure to be some of the most emotional
moments in the series.
Check out some of our newest videos right
here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel, and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.